tratemos de averiguar la configuración
electrónica del xenón y después
tomemos eso como base para explorar la
configuración electrónica de los
elementos del bloque efe en particular
trataremos de conocer la configuración
electrónica del neodimio un poco difícil
de pronunciar neodimio primero
trabajemos con el xenón los invito a que
pause en el vídeo y traten de obtener la
configuración electrónica del xenón
supondré que ya lo intentaron
ahora hagámoslo juntos tenemos 1s 2 y
luego pasamos al segundo periodo 2 s 2
después pasamos a la sub capa p entonces
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
26 y luego tenemos 3 s 2 después 36
y luego 4 s 2 a continuación pasamos al
bloque de recuerden que en el bloque de
aún cuando nos encontramos en el cuarto
periodo llenaremos la sub capa 3 de que
es el periodo menos 1 y para llenarlo
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 3 de 10
después regresamos al bloque pp y como
nos encontramos en el cuarto período nos
queda 4 p y para llenarlo tenemos 6
electrones ahora pasamos al quinto
período 5 s 2 y después tenemos el
periodo que es 5 pero en el bloque de
así que regresamos a la sub capa 4 de y
tenemos
pero de 10 y luego regresamos a 5 p 6
porque el xenón llena perfectamente toda
esa sub capa
esta es la configuración electrónica del
xenón ahora pensemos en la configuración
electrónica para el neodimio neodimio y
quizás se estén preguntando oye qué
ocurre con el bloque efe es una isla de
elementos bueno en realidad no es una
isla la razón por la que se encuentran
estos cuadros de colores es porque ahí
es en donde va el bloque efe al
colocarlo en su lugar la tabla periódica
queda más larga y los bloques de ip se
desplazan así que el bloque efe toma su
lugar en realidad así me gusta más
porque podemos ver que el bloque efe no
está tan aislado sino que en realidad
parte de la tabla periódica entonces
todo este bloque es el bloque efe muy
bien ahora vamos a obtener la
configuración electrónica para el
neodimio les daré un consejo en el
bloque de llenamos una sub capa abajo
del periodo en el que nos encontramos
pero para el caso del bloque efe
hay que regresar 2 es decir en este caso
no estaríamos llenando la sub capa 6 efe
sino más bien 4 efe vamos a ver que
tanto necesitamos agregar a la
configuración del señor para obtener la
configuración del neodimio los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y lo intenten
ustedes mismos supondré que ya lo
intentaron hagámoslo juntos el neodimio
tiene la configuración del señor porque
el xenón tiene
el mayor número atómico de los gases
nobles que es menor al número atómico
del neodimio así que podemos empezar con
esto que corresponde a lo que ya vimos y
después a esto le agregamos lo que falta
tenemos 6 ese 2 que sería esta parte
en setos y luego llenamos la sub capa
efe que no es la capa 6 recuerden que al
periodo le restamos 2 entonces sería 4
usaré otro color
y tenemos 4 electrones en esta sub capa
1 2 3 4
entonces nos queda 4
efe 4 estamos en el sexto periodo pero
como estamos en el bloque f regresamos a
llenar la cuarta capa y tenemos 1234
electrones
esta es la configuración electrónica
abreviada otra forma de escribirlo sería
poniendo todo esto déjenme copiarlo y
pegarlo
obviamente ocupará más espacio
vamos a ver entonces escribimos todo
esto y después agregamos 6 efectos
s 2 y 4 f 4 4 f 4 esta es la forma
completa de escribirlo